こんにちははじめ施設のです今回を結論の閉鎖ではなくてこちら
弊社さんの待合室からオープンさせていただきます私一市長本日実況2分させて
いただきますよろしくお願い致します
さあ皆さん歯医者というまずイメージありませんでしょうかはい今回の動画のテーマは
放置検証
歯医者の待合室で a
胃炎に放置されたらどうするのでございます最低な傾聴ですよろしくお願いしますと
いうターゲットはですね虫歯がありまして僕が際に紹介して今回1回目の歯医者らしい
です
そして本日はさあさっそくターゲットが来てまいりましたよろしくお願い致します
ピンズは私がいつ坊さんになっている静岡市笠にご協力いただいて撮影しております
けれどもうのしかず氏のもねーなーもう
はいそのいんちょ私もすべて組でございますも本人も知れませんカメラもしっかりと
隠しておかせていただいておりますさあ最初の写真
の研修別業しておりますそれで本題から虫歯の治療を始めると思いたいところなんです
けれども
今回初診は何も起きません次のが
せ切り
いただいて今問診票ですねまぁ初回なのでどこが悪いかというところ今がか右書く
ところだと思いますあお姉さんが綺麗ですが羨ましいですがここでしっかりと
症状などを書いていくところなんですけれどもこれは何も意味がありません
今回は呼ばれませんさあしっかりと支えていきますさあ他の
患者さんもどんどん入らせるところで5分が経過しました
8積極的を張ったと思ってございましょう
入っしっかり閉じ一史さんも確認してさー
新章ます形でしばらくお待ちください指ますので行って戻ったところなんですけれども
読まれませんあーあーこの後は放置が良い縁に続きますさあ
ターゲットは何を以ってどう行動するのかカエルがわからないところでありますが
しっかりと初回でもらったカードさえに入れます
さあ私もちょっと怖いです何かずっとまた大石できれて帰るんじゃないことがあると
企画を終了しなきゃいけなくなりました
放置にいつまで耐えられるのがいつから怪しいと大田花きみんなでところでさぁ
くれて見ていきましょう患者さんがどんどんどんどんぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってゆく
さあここで10分が経過しました10分が待たされることがよくあると思うんですけど
もこの歯医者に通ってるんですけどまたセレクトほぼないんですよ
もう予約制で時間も決まっているとさあここで足をクロス
しっかりと足をクロス組んで行くこれはイライラストレスがたまって
湘南でしょうかどんどん自分が住んでいく僕を結構変わってるんですけどもう予約制で
近く決まってねめっちゃスムーズ待つところなんですよ
さあここで足の黒とまくっていく依頼出しているのか
そして俺も類後に来た人ももう言われとるじゃ
達お風呂行く逆の方向にクロス組んでいきます怪しいと思っているのでしょうか
時はどんどん進んでいく30分が経過しました
達飲んで呼ばれるよ
アイカーさあまた自然が鈍感なのでしょうかそれでも小出しは fila ティック
オープンからねぇ
さあさらにさらに周りの席の人が変わっていく
おかしいおかしいぞと思ってるのか
何かおかしいな言われねーなー
そうです30分も待たされること絶対ないんですけど何か
初診ならありそうですよね超キョロキョロと微信が泳いでいきます
おかしい明らかにあなたてきた人直鎖言われてってゆーめーでー
まだまだ別の人はやバリ取りアンテといった感じ俺はどうなるんやと思いを込めつつ
さらに次元が進んで行きますさあこれ45分
がしました完全なおかしいでこれ何でみんなでの太さが気になるでといったところ
でしょうか
ちょっと伸びもしたいぐらいの時間がたっておりますいつまでまたさんが空ビ度ググる
と放置されてゆく
そして時間はさんに進んでいきますさあもうすることはスマホを見ることしかない彼の
前の患者さんの回転数がどんどんどんどん速くなって目まぐるしく変わっていく環境の
中へだけが取り残されてゆく
さあそろそろですねここで1時間半が経過しました
もうありません普通だったらありえない時間待つされております
おかしいなぁなんでやっなんで俺こんな待っとるんや
その方に行った
さらにまたされていきます結構歯医者って改善にず高いですねやっぱり
ここであるお医者様がたくさんいるんですごいペースが早いんで僕めっちゃ助かるん
じゃね待つ時間内の
暇そうですがここで2時間半が経過しましたそろそろ限界なんじゃないでしょうか
私彼のことちょっと心配だったんで何かいい加減な人っているんですけれどもどうじゃ
ないですねなんか注意良いの皆様綺麗なのでもあって毒蛇会えるとおっしゃっており
ました
彼ですね9時45分から歯医者にいいして12時からも仕事が始まっちゃうんで
ここでですねまだ呼ばれない
で帰ろうと思っていますと連絡が来たのでここで検証終了となります
急いで私が現場に向かって彼が大変のと色と思いますこれ
な話です
[音楽]
ん
dan
ban
[音楽]
ええええええ
日本人だった
[音楽]
padi
多分
はいというわけで歯医者の待合室で放置されるドッキリでした
どうでした最初ま1時間くらいは待つなあと思う5巻で会や松なーと思ってたんです
けど1時間半から2時間ぐらいのところで初めてなんですけどスって印象だしてるお客
さんと書いてすぐ呼ばれてくださっえっ
すげーすぐみんな汚れピックアップっ
終わっても
んですかん
ほお杖してみたかったんですよどういう心境になるんかなっていうのがちとアーってみ
たかったんで
的な映像も足りないんだありがとうフーリーさんとになります本当にありがとうござい
ます
入った上で今回でたくさん放置してみたわけなんですけどもなんとパ以外で
ぺちゃくちゃ人気のもう4500万だろうと超えている
王道ファンタジー rpg レー二型アリーナ棟たい
アップでございます af キャリーがどういうゲームかといいますと
育成報知システムでそので固めでカンナと仲が吸うことができます[ __ ]入学あの世界
観がめちゃくちゃ壮大なんですよ
そしてですねキャラクターが釣れたの個性豊かであの絵本とか
導入できるようなかわいいのがたくさん出てきます
今回やった放置とか意外にもいい
どんなコンテンツが豊富に含まれておりましてゲームする人でもゲームだしない人でも
大丈夫を楽しめるように書けるゲームでございます
6月の3000日から日本でも遊べるようになったということでございます
としてですねー父兄アリーナなんと sn 県のな込めるコラボも開催しております
7月中はリリース記念キャンペーン中でしてお得にガチャの秘訣はのでみなさんぜひ
概要欄からダウンロードして遊んでみてくださいって言えば今回てくださん
解放されますよね大家ですか行為や入っには将棋の搭乗口で放送してみましょう
ばいばい